agriculture is frankly one of the
reasons why many of the developing
nations of the world continue to kind of
depend on handouts for the because they
do not have an agricultural
infrastructure that allows them to be
self-sufficient in food production is
and and in the area of global trade we
really do not have very much free trade
in agriculture because it's an
interesting phenomenon no matter how
rich your country is most farmers will
want to protect what they have inside
it's as true of America it's true of the
UK it's true of Europe it's true of
China it's true of everywhere else so
agriculture is probably the reason why
we cannot move very aggressively on a
new global trade round the agricultural
interests are pretty down on that well I
think in the area of Agriculture you
know what we as a nation have to do is
have to recognize that vast areas of the
world have subsistence agriculture and
and our policies tend to hurt that
because of the way we subsidize our
products I don't want to make an overall
statement because some are more in that
area than in others and not every one of
our programs is bad but agriculture is
unique the politics of Agriculture is
unlike any and the rest of the world you
can be talking to the most liberal
progressive politician in America or
Japan or in Europe on anything else and
you mentioned dairy or cotton or sugar
and it's like they turn from dr. Jekyll
into mr. Hyde it's just it's just the
way of the world has probably always
been that way and part of it is this
natural predilection to protect your
farmers in your food supply
you